today's topics and we begin today with
the question of whether transgender high
school girls should be allowed to race
on high school girls track teams and in
Connecticut these parents have said it's
not fair I think there's a myth of it
even playing field there are all kinds
of reasons that people have advantages
somebody's parents can give them
year-round training somebody else is
really really tall and someone's really
really short I mean they're all there's
no such thing as it is a level playing
field I want to raise a little kid right
now because you box a child above the
[ __ ] child
there's no difference we just say yeah
we almost seem playing field a field the
guy he's I got hands he got a big head
Jimmy Neutron looking a little bit go
what you say about my homie where's that
key googoo gaga
[ __ ] that I'm a popular yeah come on my
stream say then you gotta let's go let's
go I don't keep you a baby that's no
less not like that let's just it's just
a it's just honest she's got hands I got
hands I got feet you got feet shoulders
knees and toes let's go where I can take
them in his mouth all right okay we
fight there's no such thing as a level
playing field
what are you saying all right I fight
okay I do Fighting's boys and stuff like
that
my wife does fighting for sports as well
my wife has more technical than me she
has more years of practice and more
years of in this game she's a black belt
at window but I am bigger faster
stronger than my wife and that's gonna
compensate for the lack of techniques
that's why even in the man's on the man
side there is weight classes and the
weight classes are like six to seven
pounds difference the whole momentum of
your body the whole mass of your body
behind that bunch can can just make the
difference between me punching someone
and it just feels like that me hurting
the person me breaking someone's born
causing a trauma it's the different and
just just a couple of pounds of pressure
with the weight of the arm and the
momentum that is that is traveling just
makes that difference it's just a couple
of pounds because if you look at the
best female runners and the best male
runners there's a gap there's a giant
gap there's a gap right just one second
can just be the whole difference rough
you lose the race about one second no
you didn't lose the worry you were not
running
look we're not even in there why was it
necessary for you to say that anybody
Terina it couldn't beat the 700 player
you threatenin sir she's the greatest
player the female player that ever lived
then the lady said to me I don't
remember which one but she said why did
you say woman why don't you just say the
greatest you know tennis player that
ever lived and so then I felt the need
to defend myself I don't know just say
what I really felt I mean which is about
what I think she would be I think you're
referring to the fact that I said she'd
be about 700 in the world yeah I'm just
waiting it would like to apologize no
you're right this pig you are a disgrace
do you make common sense and women's
sense are completely almost two separate
sports so I'm like if I were to play
Andy Murray I would lose six oh six oh
and five to six minutes maybe ten
minutes because no it's true it's
completely it's a completely different
worth the men are a lot faster and me
and they they did they serve harder they
hit highs just a different game and I
love to play women's - that's right I
only want to play girls because I don't
want to be embarrassed I would not do
the tour
power jazz I was come to realize over
over time that a lot of times people are
fighting on behalf of people who don't
want them fighting for them in an effort
to appeal to their base they're going to
implement policies that don't actually
work for people but are actually
extremely dangerous imagine if we start
to allow UFC fighters to fight with no
gender involved how women would get
completely destroyed physically and hurt
because their fighting gets people who
have a clear physiological advantage
that is dangerous you're putting
people's lives at risk of we would have
never let a bantamweight fight a
heavyweight because we recognize it is
absolutely dangerous and it risks their
life and they would never want to do it
yet what you're advocating for is
putting them in that life-threatening
situation this is why I say people like
this liberals like this who want to just
try to advocate for people thinking
they're doing a good thing
they're just virtue Singh like they want
power they want control they're not
actually implementing policies that
protect the people that they're trying
to fight for and it's also not fair to
transgender people because any time they
win at anything we're always gonna say
it's because you're trans yep it's the
truth because you have a clear advantage
if you start ten meters ahead of me I'm
like well that was probably a big party
you win if you start with more
testosterone than me because you can
check yourself I'm gonna say this
because that's why you won and if we're
playing in a sport that has weight
classes and you're ten weight classes
bigger than me and you beat me I'm going
to say that's probably why you want me I
don't think we have to reject that I
don't think that's there's not a binary
choice that if you're if you are
conflicted on this issue you're against
transgender yes excuse me black lady let
me just talk yes I was just I have a
point to me and you haven't spoken since
the beginning but now it's my turn since
I'm like shut up you you are against
them being able to compete and as the
gender that they attack well I think
they're wrestling with how to handle it
sensitively to all people involved well
the Connecticut if I could add I
actually interviewed a transgendered
person for my PBS show and we talked
about the case in Connecticut and she
said that she thought it was unfair if
this student has not been taking
hormones hasn't gone is it going through
transitions let's talk about the
hormones the focus what
happens at the NCAA level at the college
level is they say that you male to
female transgender that you need to have
been doing hormone therapy for at least
a year because the testosterone levels
they think at that level need to come
down to make it more even did you see
that clip you see that she's talking and
look at all three of their faces Wells
they think at that level need to come
down to make it more even the other one
is just an emotional response listen to
what the other side is saying and take
his you know more even because a lot of
testosterone is that's where guys get
their big muscles from and she's just
trying to interrupt you see her hand
going up so here are five signs you can
look out for to know when someone you're
speaking to is not listening sign number
one so what you mean is they're really
not trying to listen what you're saying
so what you mean is right so you think
you're saying you've done your research
and women are unhappy dominating men no
I'm not saying that I'm right and I
actually haven't said that far you're
saying it makes them miserable so you
say women are just more sensible they
don't want that because it's not a nice
luck right so you're saying that anyone
who believes in equality whether you
call them feminists call them whatever
you want to call them should basically
give up or cuz it ain't gonna happen
only if they're aiming at equality of
outcome
so you're saying gives I said what I
said I don't need you to paraphrase what
the [ __ ] I said I said it if you listen
to it you would have know where the [ __ ]
I said I said that I'll try to
paraphrase it only thing me trying to
know is or trying to tell you is what
the cell you said it wasn't listening so
what you mean is you hard-of-hearing
igger
and your ears don't work second thing
you can look out for is if their hand
goes up planet ADAP and this day they're
number three when their mouth moves
before you're done talking if I'm taking
the time to say things to you and you're
pretending like you're listening but
your mouth is already moving [ __ ] can
you time travel can you already finished
argue something I haven't done or is you
finished I asked you a question
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's the start of a great conversation
and the end of it [ __ ] I'm out we're not
talking in it that's a non verse Asian
that's not a conversation that's a great
but here's the problem if you're a kid
those are adults okay if you're a kid
you don't have that option in many
circumstances in some states and many
said you can't begin that until you're
over sixteen I think we netiquette may
be one of them they are right I just
want to make sure I'm understanding what
you're saying in terms of of everyone
being at some sort of disadvantage are
you saying
the boys and girls at the age of 14 or
15 are the same physically no what I'm
saying though although a lot of doctors
say that some boys mature faster in
terms of their physicality and some
girls mature faster and you know in the
wonderful research packet provided by
your producers there are a lot of
references including a Yale physician
who says you know it's just a myth that
all boys are stronger and faster than
all girls nobody says that all boys are
faster and stronger than all women if I
fight Ronda Rousey she's gonna have a
field day with my butthole it's okay
she's gonna have a field day
male British rapper claims to have
broken the woman's a weightlifting
record while identifying as female in
his post he outlined that he was
identifying as a woman we spoke to him I
think the video went viral because it
touched on a timely issue according to
their own logic they have no proof that
I myself did not identify as a woman
whilst doing that video so by their own
logic I could easily accuse them of
being transphobic or being bigoted by
claiming that I in fact was not a woman
at the time that video was recorded a
young woman in Connecticut won the 500
right she won the 500 right what
competing ready that means nothing we're
not saying that some girls cannot beat
some guys all right yes it's possible
that some women stupid our viewers are
intelligent of to decipher how stupid
this [ __ ] land if you take the top of
males and the top of females the gap is
huge and look this is not a transphobic
thing we're not against trans people and
you want to know how I know this is the
kids because nobody's fighting
transgender men okay I want to compete
against other men in sports why because
there is no advance in fact there at a
severe disadvantage you have not heard
of any transgender men who are breaking
records playing against men but you are
hearing about every transgender woman
breaking almost every record that a
natural cisgender woman has held and
look for me it's crazy it's crazy for me
to think that such a small population of
people okay or somehow some of the most
elite athletes is it possible that this
is an anomaly or just maybe just maybe
these
people why the physiology of a man have
physical advantages and when they
compete against women you're seeing
those specific advantages between
testosterone and performance the female
range for testosterone if you don't
think that juicing doesn't make a
difference there's a reason why it's
banned at the Olympics there's a reason
why it's banned in every professional
sports not what did this for your
recovery and your muscle building
studies are unbelievable everything it's
everything quite a title 9 which created
the federal requirement to have girls
sports and have schools recognize girls
athleticism and competition in sport was
to do this to recognize - and create
sports programs for girls because before
that it was all for boys by her rules
was gonna happen is that men are gonna
be in all the sports I think we don't
nothing tennis is not woman and man
tennis it's just tennis what's gonna
happen we would never have Serena would
you would never have Serena Williams
these people want diversity is not
diversity in the pink that's the reality
of the problem at hand
I think the most troubling part about
this video wasn't the fact that she had
terrible arguments the fact that she
wasn't listening and without listening
abilities you can't have dialogue it
doesn't matter what happens if I come to
you and I'm saying hey when I say a
whole spiel about how I'm feeling and
then the responses I want to double
cheeseburgers we had no dialogue
none I know what you want to eat but you
didn't understand what I'm feeling and
what I'm actually going through so we
can't understand each other and that's
the problem with our society right now
is that we are not listening to what
people are saying
liberals got mad at John McCrae for what
he said about Serena wins when Serena
Williams was echoing his very same
thoughts about her not wanting to
compete against men because it's not
fair I would just caution people to in
the name of progressiveness stop trying
to change the world actually listen to
what's going on listen to the parties
that would be most affected and see what
solutions actually sound plausible but
don't inject yourself in situations
where you don't understand the
parameters and then try to make change
because that is misguided if I don't
understand
why this house is in shambles it makes
no sense to hire me to fix it because if
I try to fix it and then I bring the
next family in and it falls they die
because I didn't know what the [ __ ] I
was doing when I got in here if you
don't play sports and you've never
played sports and you don't understand
sports you probably shouldn't be out
there deciding what competition in
sports should look like if you're not
from the hood don't come to muffled
that's right [ __ ]
[Music]